then you're watching book TV on c-span 2
it's television for serious readers
we're in New York City at the publishers
annual trade show and what we like to do
during the summer is preview some of the
fall books that are coming out next up
we want to introduce you to Zoe Quinn
she is the author of this book crash
override how gamergate nearly destroyed
my life and how we can win the fight
against online hate zoe quinn what do
you do for a living I usually do if I
make weird art but ultimately I guess my
day job is an independent game developer
but I also help running a crisis
resource center for people are being
targeted by online harassment
well we'll get to that but let's go to
the gamer part of that what exactly do
you do a lot of stuff since I'm an
independent game developer that means
that I make most of the stuff on my own
or with small teams so I'm a programmer
a writer and artist I do some sound
design I usually work with composer
because nobody needs to hear my terrible
riot girl music ever again
but it's a little bit of everything and
I try to make amateur people who don't
normally think that games are for them
explore subjects that aren't usually
tackled what's one of the games that
you've developed that maybe an audience
that's familiar with that knows I think
I'm probably best known for my game
depression clutchless which is an
interactive fiction game about living
with depression and
describe what happens in this game are
you on a console like a ps4 or something
no I try to make my design as accessible
as possible to as many people as
possible so it's simply run from the
website you just go to the website and
they control the very simple you're
given sort of a situation like and
everyday thing like your partner calls
you and asks you go to a party and what
it presents the player is what's like
some choices and there's the normal
healthy option of like oh yeah just go
out and have fun with your friends it's
always crossed off in red and then
you're sort of given a bunch of other
options but try to show through getting
the player to actually do instead of
show don't tell it's like do don't show
what it's like for the depression that's
not simply a bad mood that you can just
snap out of and sort of it's a game
about taking things away and removing
player agency how did you get into this
work I actually learned from other
independent game developers the
community is really active and really
welcoming we a lot of us are either
self-taught or we have left larger
Studios sort of your own say so there's
this big spirit of community and giving
back and making resources available to
other people to come in and try to learn
how to make their own game how big is
this world of game pretty big it's I
mean like just consider how many times
have been on public transit and people
are playing games on their phone like
that's like an entire league almost
everybody plays games now so it's
enormous
and then encompasses everything stored
games video games the phone games -
there's people making really cool art
installation games and like interactive
experiences that took place in the set
building
something happened to you while you were
gamer and that's what your book is about
what happened what happened is a
particularly stifle and abusive
ex-boyfriend out there I finally found a
lot of my life decided that if you can't
control me in the self anymore he tried
to get the Internet to do it for him he
posted this extremely long rambling blog
post that he specifically engineered
because as much harm as possible to
myself and make me basically the perfect
target for all the different to
capitalize on sort of this undercurrent
of hatred towards progressive people
marginalized people in games and on the
Internet at large and just sort of give
like wrapped me up in a nice little bow
and give them to the target he actually
workshops how to sort of make this post
go viral like people do with marketing
campaigns except instead of like trying
to sell them it's trying to ruin your
ex-girlfriends life how close could he
come
we've worked quite well I still get
constant uh press my family folks gets
constant death threats they circulated
nude photos with me they found out where
I lived
one person spent upwards of five years
on hiring a CI to hang out and do
research into me and dig through my
trash is caught on outside of gaming
with a fringe right wing like what
people are now calling the old right but
back then they didn't have a word for it
all of them just sort of I was a target
to juror especially because I refused to
back down and called it what it was
and then just hide what does this have
to do with politics why is this a
alright thing blowing one of the first
people to capitalize on this was newly
novelist
Breitbart has run numerous pieces about
me about my family I think the first one
was called lying grating promiscuous
feminist ELISA riveting video games and
that link to like that it linked to nude
photos of me and my dad's home address
and stuff like that
and they just sort of I was a complete
it's really extremely personal and not
personal at all at the same time because
I was a community abandon for all this
anxiety from the gaming side of what the
fact that so many new people are from
all different walks of life are making
games themselves and for people like
them and they're sort of that like oh no
this is mine you can't be here element
of it and then there's just the entire
element of people who like yelling at
anybody they perceived to be remotely
feminist even if you're feminism amounts
to please stop sending any death threats
online so it's really just there's so
many accesses of a nightmare trash that
lined up perfectly I was in the wrong
place at the wrong time I guess zoe
quinn when you first found this blog
post online
where were you how did you find it it's
on me and I was actually out with
friends with my new boyfriend
we were about to he was about to accept
a job in France and I was going to go
stay with him for three months like
crash on floor since I can do what I do
from wherever in the world and we were
celebrating my birthday and then my
phone just started buzzing and buzzing
and buzzing and buzzing and it's sort of
like counting the time between
thunderclap see how far the storm is
like the time just between buzzes got
shorter and shorter and my cell is just
filling up with all of like slurs really
really sexually charged threats
and I sort of had to work backwards from
that all I knew was a friend of mine it
said oh hey I don't know if you know
this but somebody just registered on the
account of these forums and posted this
like really far out there thread about
you it got deleted immediately so he had
shots like shopped it around in
different forums until finally a place
that didn't care
picked it up ran with it and I just
watched from for the rest of the night
because I had already gotten used to
screenshotting everything contestants
against limiting getting has been an
issue for quite some time and one of the
biggest things people don't believe you
so I have like a recorded history of
everything like gigabytes and gigabytes
of people of this unfolding so it's a
very weird sort of excavation effort and
reading this book so your book crash
override where did that title came from
so it came from what I think is more
important in the story which is what we
did about it my boyfriend of the time
help me profound heart override these
two for a while call a meet friend throw
what we would call pre hacking drinks
because the attacks are so frequent for
the next few months that it was like if
we left the computer for more than ten
minutes we come back to something the
engine fire so we had a laptop with us
battery chargers mobile hotspot so that
no matter where we were we to get online
and sure enough another independent game
developer had gotten hacked so he and I
sorta went into action while we were out
with a friend he's like oh you guys
remind me of that movie hackers so crash
override was one of the handles from
that I really got that you know at heart
I'm the comedian I love candy cinema
like that so we sort of gave it that
name and also because the meaning of
like over writing this thing crashing
down around you felt like I had that
double meaning that was really important
to me because I didn't want this
supposed to just be about oh look at
this terrible thing that happened the
entire second half is well what did I do
about it what can we do about it what
have we been doing about it what does
what works
dozen and that's really the book I
wanted to write when did you get
involved to the gaming world was this in
your youth I grew up pretty isolated so
I was a gamer but kind of a weird one
like I didn't have a Nintendo or a
Playstation growing up my dad had a
gotten this console called a 3do
which had shipped in 1993 and
immediately died because it was not the
best idea it was like $700 at launch and
it was a big push into FMV which is
using video of actors instead of like
computer-generated graphics as like oh
you can't get better graphics than like
real people except like all of the
acting is really terrible and most of
the games aren't that good so I grew up
playing that and being kind of a weird
kid about it and it wasn't until later
that I got in the mainstream consoles in
computer gaming kind of garbage computer
I'd cobbled together from spare parts
but if it ran more than a once the
messenger and Firefox at the same time
it would crash so it took me a while to
actually get into mainstream gaming I
was sort of like always about 10 years
behind my dad had gotten the console at
a garage sale in I think 97 or 99 I
forget so like way after it was said
nobody was we came for it so at a very
limited thing for quite some time aside
from a gameboy that I had and but I
started to meet other gamers online and
that's really when I sort of entered
sort of a community and started playing
some games competitively it wasn't until
I was 23 that I even knew I could make a
game myself why shouldn't that sound
silly it seemed like this magical thing
that happened with hundreds of people
somewhere else not something I could do
myself
were you one of the few women yeah at
that point I mean it's hard to say
because it's like there's definitely
always been a lot of people who aren't
men and games but like they don't get as
much mobility and support or if they do
if they get attacked so it's like a
trade-off the numbers are smaller for
sure but it's it's like definitely I
think underestimated how many of us
there are but still there's not it is
from your book crash override we really
need to interrogate the traditional
wisdom that mostly white mostly male
mostly Western decision-makers have
touted his answers to online harassment
and we need a truly diverse range of
thinkers to be actively welcomed into
the conversation what's the background
on me
I think that statement largely came from
going to a number of of Silicon Valley
companies that pressure brides work with
to establish like channel where if
someone comes to us and they're having a
crisis immediately you can then go to
our tech partners and say hey this we've
we've built this relationship you've
trained us on your Terms of Service we
know what they are we know that this is
something that you don't want to happen
on your platform can you take action on
this immediately otherwise you know the
reporting systems are dealing with like
a significant volume of stuff that's
just nothing right but the problem I
would run into so much there's that you
know everybody that I was talking to in
high and leadership positions were white
men who or white women who thought that
involving the police for example was the
best possible situation which doesn't
make sense if you know if you're already
a marginalized person who's
disproportionately targeted by
harassment and we live in a country
where the police can be used because
stuff like swatting where people get
your home address call in a fake bomb
threat of EPs happening at your house
hoping that a SWAT team will go to your
house that you'll think someone's
breaking and it resists and that they'll
shoot you dead like saying that that
institution that has you know had
numerous issues with violence towards
marginalized people being the solution
to a problem that marginalized people
disproportionately face is tone-deaf and
waiting for a lot to catch up and
pushing off all the responsibility is
like onto oh well we just need better
laws or oh we definitely more arrest is
negligent it's not and it's like every
time I would be in these rooms usually
with other people who you know were
brought in to have that viewpoint
alongside ours would have the same
conversations over and over having to
tell these basic facts like no this is
not relevant to my experience with
marginalized person and
did you even think about like dead
naming policies which is a specific sort
of violence usually directed at trans
people or they find like pretended
student information and threatened or
harassed them with it's like most a lot
of tech companies weren't even thinking
about that being a form of harassment it
just looks like a name to them so it's
like how could that be Erasmus it's not
threat so that's one of the reasons why
I like more perspective is needed
Silicon Valley is a major issue we're
very insular those people making our
laws are very fit there's not at times
diversity there either so having it
having everybody who sort of makes these
decisions and not have these
perspectives is frustrating and I can't
even give all of them because I have my
own limitations and stuff like that
here's the book it's called crash
override how gamergate nearly destroyed
my life and how we can win the fight
against online hate it publishes in
September the author Zoe put thank you